[Music]
you
Philon min ago CEO of Michelin welcome
to Stanford and systems leadership hi
Rob
very nice being with you so tell us a
little bit about how Michelin is dealing
with all of the changes in the mobility
industry the very interesting question a
lot of people think today Mishnah is a
tire company but we have a much redder
scheme we think that the reason why we
are together is because we care about
giving people a better way forward so
the best expression of this aspiration
this purpose of a company is through
tires but actually we are developing in
many other domain related to a better
mobility because we are convinced that a
better mobility is good for human
progress so you have a company that's
been around for over a hundred years a
deep rich tradition and France and all
over the world how is the leadership
team evolving and changing the culture
given the massive changes in your
customers and your channels your
suppliers etc oh yeah it's a it's a it's
a great question I think we are living
through a revolution that is only
happening every 400 or 500 years so it's
it's massive and it's hitting the
company everywhere the good thing is as
we are hundred and thirty year all
company we have been through a lot of
different times war time economic crisis
that also so as a company we've learned
how to live through these massive events
right now we are not taking a massive
transformation in many many directions
technology people managerial businesses
and you cannot imagine the number of
transformation we have actually we know
we have an IT system roadmap we do the
same for our transformation it's getting
so massive and so complex that but
people understand why we're doing it and
therefore we're gonna win
with that so today we'll be talking with
the students about globalization and you
interacting and michelin is a global
company and in particular obviously
China has a rising power of large market
how is Michelin dealing with not only
the opportunities in China but the rise
of new competitors coming out of China
yeah I use a frequently a very nice word
which is glocal as a corporation's we
have to act in a global manner to get
the synergies to get the rationalization
to get the efficiency however to meet
customer expectations everywhere we are
we have to be extremely local so in the
u.s. believe it or not a lot of people
think that Mishnah is American in France
of course people think Mishnah is French
but in China other people think mitch
lin is chinese and that's how we grow is
we we try to be as local as possible
when it makes sense and at the global as
possible when we need it
when it's make more sense from the
business point of view how special I'm
thinking about adding services to the
business you know there's a telematics
parts to your business you're looking at
digitization of tires how does all of
that fit into the big picture of the
blending of physical and digital for the
corporation you know the way we look at
it and the way I look at it is that
everything will be digital at me now
because technology will enhance
everything we do will be more savvy
about our customers will be faster in
responding to constantly evolving needs
technology is transforming the customers
behaviors so therefore as a
corporation's we also have to adapt very
fast using technology to be able to meet
this new customer that we have in front
of us this customer wants to be to
become what I call a consume actor not
not only a consumer they don't want to
be the object of consumption they want
to be acting in their consumption which
is a very different way of acting
instead of having a few market segments
to serve I said to our teams now we have
billions of markets to serve why
billions because every single person
every single company every single entity
a new market so we have to be extremely
efficient in Russian izing what we do at
the same times we have to develop the
enhance services that are going to match
every individual needs that's what I
call the new marketing for billions so
if you think about these new
opportunities you think about the global
nature and what you do how do you think
about bringing new talent into the
company and blending new digital
capabilities with a company that's very
very rich in particular say material
science and manufacturing that's the big
challenge it's been over decades the
same challenge is how do you bring the
competencies how do you make those
competencies compatible with the
existing culture how do you make evolve
the culture of the company to attract
talent we need in various domains so we
have more than 350 different type of
skills developed in just research we
have hundreds of different type of
skills required in marketing and that
was mentioning billions of markets we
probably probably have now to recruit
new type of market ears that understand
how to use data to make sure that our
offerings whether product or services
are meeting the customer needs so all
these are transforming so new skills are
developing and my take is that in five
years
50% of the jobs in Mishnah are not
defined today so a lot of opportunities
for people to join because a lot of
things we recruit people for what they
are not for the skills they have
developed but for the for what they are
and develop development will be with the
company so Florence you've recently
become the CEO you're about to take over
officially though you've been in that
capacity and you want to bring in a new
leadership style new capabilities but
you don't want to lose the rich
tradition that has made mishel and who
the company is how do you think about
that as you take on the the new position
inside of your organization absolutely
the is in these stories is part of what
makes mission on what it is today so we
we are very successful company and but
if we want to bring it further
so we have to accompany the
transformation of the world so then the
question is how do we keep and how do we
enhance what we have so for example I we
have values of respect say okay now the
next step is instead of just having
respect which is in itself very strong
as a value one we look at carrying so
carrying becomes our new respect instead
of having communities in different part
of the world when we say the world is
our new community and there are many
things like that we are transforming and
making steps that encapsulate all our
history but bring it in a much more
modernized way and Mishnah is modernized
itself several times during the hundred
and thirty years formal thank you so
much for coming to Stanford and sharing
with us all of the exciting things going
on inside of the organization was a
pleasure thank you rob
merci
[Music]